his vitals are dropping we're losing him
we really want to upload we could be
together forever
you're so amazing but forever is just
like uploads that way Oh ours the other
way what do you want to do
three two one upload hello in Athens ten
fingers and toes pretty seamless this is
the first day of the rest of your
afterlife
welcome to Lakeview uplifting news
timeless Americana this one do I dare
dare you boundaries you denied in-app
purchase required this is what you look
like for real you're not some old dude
or something no this is me do real cutie
so I understand you're in a bad place
yesterday ah it's only weird if you make
it weird
[Music]
you're dead man
there's a guy in the blank entities in
computers you know you can walk on water
whenever you want no way I'm not even
supposed to be here nobody feels like
they should be here you think I wanted
to fall into the Grand Canyon that's how
you died they should expect people to
try and break the glass floor I saw that
video you dabbed on the way down that's
how you hit the lights
[Music]
you